recent reports cybercrime is now costing
the world trillions of dollars every
year the US has seen a number of massive
cyber attacks in 2017
uber Verizon anthem Microsoft's Xbox and
Google were hacked impacting at least
144 million customers the wanna cry
attack locked people in nearly every
country out of their data and for some
users to pay a ransom and the Equifax
hack exposed the data of more than 145
million Americans with us now to look at
the biggest threats will face in 2018
it's Greg Clark CEO of the cybersecurity
giant Symantec Greg great to have you
with us that was quite frightening it
was all the list of attacks we've had
this year I tell you there's never a
dull day in cybersecurity it is a
fascinating space and every day
something happens it happens I'd say
working at Symantec is is an honor and I
sometimes some of the things I see we
should get movie rights it's you know
well a lot of them are distracting
disturbing time efficient and the time
inefficient but when you look at the
wanna cry attack that impacted hospitals
people's health were at risk can we
expect more of that in here I would I
would say that you know extortion ransom
and and things like that a hey this day
you know we've seen even hackers
investing in tools for other hackers to
build ransomware extortion malware that
can be widely deployed when you see
something like one a cry which was a
worm it has exponential expansion
capabilities which means it can get
everywhere really fast when you see
something like that it is a crisis it is
something that we have to really really
be careful with but I tell you what that
the extortion and ransoms and things
like that are here to stay people are
making money and you know they're
they're enabled so you think it's gonna
get worse for us and what should we do
is as individuals to protect ourselves
people think about companies yeah but
individuals need to worry about don't do
and I think the cyber cyber crime
problem cyber defense problem splits
into two areas like you mentioned care
which is there's a corporate side a
government side that has to have extreme
care and we can talk about that then
there's a consumer side which is where
all of us normal citizens need to take
responsibility for some things
take care of our digital safety our
cyber safety and there's some simple
things that we should do like all of us
should we should always try to get a
multi-factor authentication that means a
more than just a username password many
of the banks and financial institutions
will call you back and say hey Gregor's
is you that's really important and then
I think also taking care of taking
responsibility for your identity in
cyberspace is an extremely important
thing and what this means is you know
this isn't just about credit cards
people can mint a driver's license they
can apply for a second mortgage they can
apply for a mortgage and your kids name
they can make a fraudulent healthcare
claim and so people steal identity
information to manufacture but how do we
know that's happening Greg so sorry
there is services that you that you can
get we make one called life lock and and
what happens is you you get a callback
that says hey are you leasing this
Corvette in Sacramento right now and if
you say no it's not me that causes a
bunch of things to happen that really
try to take care of your identity and I
think these are important things you
know the the responsibility of the
identity of yourself your family your
loved ones is extremely important we
call this digital safety we think it is
kind of a new category that consumers
need to step up to some people know to
be careful when they're at a keyboard
but what about when they've got a
virtual TV or one of these personal
assistants they're always listening and
how what should we be thinking about
this so I think I think you know what
every time you have a piece of Internet
enabled consumer electronics that means
it wants to get on the Wi-Fi it wants to
talk to your iPad your iPhone your
Android and you control it from there it
can be a toy can be a camera commute
doorbell you know these things are all
got computers in them and those
computers have vulnerabilities and over
time criminals understand what those
vulnerabilities are and they can put
their own software in your home consumer
electronics this is you know the
internet had a problem this time last
year the thing we call the DynaTAC which
stopped a bunch of subs like Netflix and
other things it was executed by consumer
electronics that had bad software in it
what do you do if you what do you do if
you have that you should put in some you
to put in some technology that helps
clean up all of the neighborhood around
known bad inside those houses and inside
your house and known good
we are recently launched a protocol that
Norton core router it's a home Wi-Fi
router you put it in your house
and what it does is it washes all the
consumer electronics it knows what good
is it knows what normal is when it sees
a deviation from normal it will do
things like take it offline and let you
know that that has a problem we think
you know that consumers should take
responsibility for the safety of the
network inside your house it is a place
of criminal activity and there are
technologies that can help clean it up
and we think that this will become more
and more of a problem you know we
recently launched this product and the
Roo and the telemetry you know the
information that we get about what's
happening inside the house is is is you
know fascinating there is a lot of
electronics in there many devices per
home and a lot of it is compromised like
you said a big problem for consumers for
companies for governments every world as
well exactly
Greg thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate it thank you happy holidays
yeah happy holidays thank you very much